non-minimalists
ray do you feel aspects of the
minimalist aesthetic
creeping are into trendy clothing
if yes how so so is minimalist style
creeping into the trendy the trend i
think it's it's it's moving more away
from it it was
trendy for a while but now but i look at
like kanye west and like the minimalist
house
and that seems like very trendy to me
there's a few brands that do it like
jerry lorenzo at fear of god kind of
does that where like his essentials line
which is basically like
very subdued type text and stuff i think
that's got probably
minimalist vibes or um scott disick has
a
clothing line that's basically blank
t-shirts and hoodies
i mean i i think that those things will
are a bit more timeless in the sense
like you're right like james dean for
example you drop him back in the 1300s
like he's gonna look weird
but yeah for the last you know for the
last 50 years in the next 50 years
like it's going to be in style so i
think that
uh in the sense of trendy being
something that's
ephemeral it's less ephemeral minimalist
style is less ephemeral but
i think that it certainly can be trendy
right but
what i'm saying is that many of the
trendy things that you feature on your
account for example they have at least
especially within the last two years or
so have really
moved away from a minimalist aesthetic
and toward a more
i i don't there's there's retro aspects
of the sort of
the chaos of the 90s that that's in them
and then there's also something new
that's there as well
but it's a lot of colors it's a lot of
uh text and weird places
and it's not minimalist in the same way
that i think of
like kanye west's mansion is a
minimalist mansion it's very intentional
which
i actually look at it as timeless i
don't i don't see that as being trendy
yeah
yeah it's yeah i don't know man it's
weird yeah because there are there are
uh
very minimalist um houses in los angeles
in general
that were built back in the 50s 60s 70s
yes
is that mid mod type yeah exactly that
totally that totally look
trendy but it's but it's been trendy
though for the last 50 years
trendy coming back yeah right yeah maybe
which is actually our last question
from shaldo uh why do we see some
clothing trends come back
into style well i mean i think what
hopefully the charitable view is we look
at to the past and say let's carry
forward the things
that uh we would get some true religion
genes
on amazon
[Laughter]
so the mid-century modern is a good
example that in mid-century modern homes
like
that aesthetic became
fashionable again and thus it it did
lend to a particular trend especially in
the teens
specifically uh of the last decade
and we saw it and people started selling
it west elm had their
mid-century modern whatever but
we see this in close as well and my
there's some sort of
infinite regressive loop
uh because the things that came back in
the style like
the 80s came back in the style for a few
years and then
it was portions of the 80s and then the
90s and then like
it was recursive because then we'd go
back and be elements from 83 and then 92
and like
it it became attenuated each time so
that like
tommy hilfiger came back in the style
for six months yeah
whereas in the 90s when ryan were in
high school
it was in it was in style all of high
school like tommy hilfiger was trendy
all of the time we were in high school
then it came back for six months and
then it's gone again
yeah it is that has something to do with
our access to immediate media
right so yeah yeah i think and it but
it's also
influenced by the word you hate
i think influencers i mean people that
are seen as icons
definitely drive some of that the people
that i mean like
i keep talking about justin bieber i'm
not obsessed with justin bieber but he's
just very prevalent in this whole
culture like sure he started wearing
those dumpy
pants that like have a super low crotch
right whatever i don't know what those
are called
but people started wearing those like
really unattractive
type pants but when people like that
start to wear things they
choose they get to dictate kind of what
the culture sees as
fashionable yeah and it's nothing
sinister or it's nothing like i don't
think
planned but it is driven by our access
to those type of people that
yeah have a ton of reach well also and
we look at those people as
cool people for whatever reason and this
is the
this is what was different from the the
james deans or
the the malcolm x or whomever was cool
back in the day
there wasn't a shortcut to be cool like
them yeah you couldn't put on the
you couldn't put on the white shirt in
jeans and be james dean
um and it would look it would look silly
um and and now people feel as though
they can put on the drew shirt and look
like justin bieber right
um and i think about that is like
i get why we say some of these people
are are cool but the coolest people i
know are people like leo babalta
you saw him he was in our first
documentary he has six kids and he's a
he's like ultra minimalist he makes ryan
and me look
silly right he's got one shirt for each
kid
[Music]
[Laughter]
and he's a minimalist with condoms for
sure
[Laughter]
but yeah and so but he's like
literally one of the coolest people i
know i couldn't tell you a single brand
that he
he wears but he sort of embodies cool
and it doesn't matter to me what
what what he wears there's no shortcut
to be like leo babalta
i mean the the the most direct path is
to
meditate for an hour a day and shave
your head yeah write daily
and and to be silent most of the time
isn't it interesting how some of those
people just it seems like naturally
they're just
cooler than everyone else yeah what is
that i want to tap into that yeah
although i mean justin bieber uh is i i
get it i
uh i've been in a sauna with him before
he was the only other person there i
walk in this room i'm like
that sure looks like oh that's just
and like we're the only two people at
the russian bathhouse which is not far
from here
and and he does a few things really well
he's
he's really good at hiding like even in
plain sight he's able to hide really
well and
unfortunately like you said he couldn't
just go to a church in arkansas or
wherever because
he would be mobbed um and
and so there's quite the burden there as
well so i think there's a
an extra layer of cool that we assign to
someone like that because they're forced
to
um i don't know to learn these weird
sort of tactics in order just to be
semi-human they're not human to us
because they're not treated like your
average human being
yeah and it's got to be a difficult life
i wouldn't wish that on on anyone
you